Honeypots can be deployed in
a variety of locations on a network.
A honeypot outside the external
firewall is useful for
tracking attempts to scan or
attack the internal network.
The main advantages of placing
the honeypot at this location are that.
First of all,
it does not have any side effect.
Second, since it attracts and traps
attacks to the honey pot, it reduces
the amount of traffic, in particular
the attack traffic to the firewall.
Therefore, it reduces
the amount of alerts
produced by the external firewall.
On the other hand,
honeypot at this location does
not trap internal attackers.
A honeypot can also be placed in a DMZ
to trap attacks to
the public facing service.
On the other hand,
a honeypot at this location may not
be able to trap interesting attacks.
This is because a DMZ is
typically not fully accessible.
That is, other than the well
defined public facing services,
no other services are supposed
to be available in DMZ.
That is, if an attacker is
attempting to access the honeypot.
And the service is not one
of these well-defined,
public facing services, the firewall
is going to block the traffic.
What if you say, let the firewall
allow the traffic to the honeypot.
But this would mean that we're
opening up the firewall.
And this is a security risk.
We can also place the honeypot
in the internal network
alongside with servers and workstations.
The main advantages here are that
it can catch internal attacks.
It can also detect
a misconfigured firewall
that forwards impermissible traffic from
the internet to the internal network.
On the other hand,
unless we can completely trap
the attacker within the honeypot.
The attack may be able to reach other
internal systems from the honeypot.
In addition,
in order to continue to attract and
trap the attackers to the honeypot,
we must allow his attack traffic
from the internet to their honeypot.
This means that we must open up the
firewall to allow the attack traffic to
come from the Internet to
the internal network, and
this carries a huge security risk.